Well then
, change the place and wait for the details of the plan for
a moment.  In the
first place, you're dismissing people
without permission, and now you're asking for
something, isn't there an appropriate attitude?
Then you're so pissed off that you want to burn it off with my breath,
but if you go that far,
Master will get angry at you.
And I'm just
joking--I'm the
hero Arios, prostrating down on the ground to such incompetence,
there's no way they'll admit that I'm stupid That
's
right, we
're not doing anything wrong
As expected, it's unpleasant It
's probably because of your
upbringing Hold on to the reins of your pet,
oh yeah.
What's wrong with calling
a beast
a pet?  It's just a battle against the Beast
I'm a hero,
I'll hit you as many times as I want
[music]